Prime Minister you just described labour
doing a deal that it says it doesn't
want to do as a prospect made in hell
that we're going up from chaos and ruin
how far we're going to get on the on the
on the fear ometer well I think it is
very very worrying because we haven't
had in our recent history an example of
a Nationalist Party but one part of the
United Kingdom playing a part in the
government of the whole of the United
Kingdom saying very frankly I'll make ed
Miliband Prime Minister I'll write the
first budget you can't have Trident
submarines unless you you know we're
going to cut all these other aspects of
Defense hs2 won't be built in the way
that all the parties the United Kingdom
up to now have agreed that's only in 24
hours those three examples I've just
given you that I think calling that a
chilling prospect or a frightening
prospect I think that is not an
understatement not an overstatement I'm
afraid but the latent labor have won't
sign up to any of those policy position
we will sign up to a coalition but
labour have been asked you know dozens
of times do you rule out having any
formal arrangement with the SMP and they
won't answer the question again in the
last 24 hours Andy Burnham Health's
shadow health secretary Angela Eagle
shadow leader of the House of Commons
saying well let's wait and see and I'm
sure we'll talk to everybody and perhaps
there are things we can do together I
think genuinely this is a very
frightening prospect the SNP love nicola
sturgeon is a deeply plausible
politician and speaks very clearly and
all the rest of it she's only got one
major aim in life and that is to break
up the United Kingdom these separatists
they're not interested in making the
Westminster Parliament stronger we ask
yourself this question does Nicola
Sturgeon at the end of five years want
people to look back and go oh well that
was a good
government in Westminster the
Westminster Parliament's working well
for me no of course not choose to break
up the Westminster Parliament and break
up our country but that's just minority
government the Labour have said nothing
other than if if the parliamentary
arithmetic falls like that they'd have
to consider the views of all the
minority parties that's just how it
would they they should rule they should
do what I'm doing which is to rule out
any form of arrangement with the essays
physically what sort of SNP MPs going
through the division are physically stop
them voting but you can stop any form of
conversation or agreement or
understanding with them because there is
no understanding you can reach with the
group of people that want to break up
your kind of hungry hang on though when
you a conservative leader in 2007 you
must have green lighted Annabelle
Goulding supporting the SNP in a
minority governments in holy but there's
a world of difference because of course
in the Holyrood Parliament that is a
parliament that the SNP thinks ought to
exist did you give permission for that
arranged I talked to animal gold or get
all those and you said yes we were so
have conservatives among minority as a
SNP there's a huge difference because
the Hollywood Parliament is something
the SNP believe it right the Westminster
Parliament they think should be
abolished they think the United Kingdom
shouldn't exist so this is not a group
of friendly people coming to come coming
down to Westminster with some good ideas
for how to run Britain all they want to
do is to create a set of circumstances
where the breakup of our country becomes
more likely you could have pulled the
plug on the Alex Salmond government
back in 08 09 when he was struggling to
pass the budget but you allowed your
Scottish leadership to continue there's
a well it wouldn't be here they don't
even had a rougher one there's a world
of difference between what happens in
Holyrood a parliament that the SNP
believe in and what I was in Westminster
Parliament than the SNP who believe it
can I take you back to sep tember the
19th to 7am when you made that speech
after the referendum at 5am Alistair
Darling calls you and says do not do not
do this you're letting Alex Salmond back
in the front door isn't the truth you're
saying that there are threats from labor
and the SNP but your actions at 7am let
the SNB back in the game when they
finally defeat I don't accept that for a
moment the SMP the proposition of
separation was defeated and that remains
the case but as Prime Minister I think
is right to speak for the whole of the
United Kingdom and I think it's quite
right that just as we've delivered on
Scottish devolution we're going to
deliver more on Welsh the evolution
we've maintained that and actually
strengthened the institutions in
Northern Ireland so it's time for the
English voice to be heard as well and
stoking up English lessons no not at all
i don't think the English are
nationalistic at all but what I think
people in England want to know is just
as there is the ability of Scottish MPs
now to set their own effectively set
their own income tax rate so English MPs
and the Westminster Parliament should be
able to do the same thing so they leave
a reasonable proposition I mean ask
yourself this question why is it that
EDD Miliband is happy to work with me on
Scottish devolution Welsh devolution
Northern Irish division who when it
comes to England he won't even have that
conversation so frightened this year of
this issue which i think is completely
wrong hey your speech today talks about
this Carlile principal
it seems to be in the back of your mind
and if you look at the work the Scottish
conservatives did that there is a vein
of thought that sees Britain becoming a
bit more federal August could you
imagine if federalized the amending
about the following I don't think it
falls on a federal-state works because
when you look at the united kingdom
england is so much bigger than the other
part I think you'll be very unbalanced
federal systems I think what we have to
do is to make devolution work better in
the nations of our United Kingdom so
Scottish and Welsh parliaments in my
view that should have these tax raising
powers so they're not just organizations
for spending money they got
responsibility for raising it and then
in England I think what we need is some
the ability for English MPs to have the
decisive say over those matters that
affect England then I think it'll so
this you could settle down we haven't
reached a resting place on this issue
and that's what I badly want us to reach
so you were talking a good life at the
manifesto launched last week and now we
have images of health from an SNP
supported label you are at the rally I
was just speaking out of the first half
of which was very clear about the
positive message about a plan that's
working 2 million more people in work
750 15 hours more businesses a strongly
growing economy I mean there's an
incredibly positive message and positive
offer from the Conservative Party but I
don't hide from people the fact that
there is a choice all of this is put at
risk I admit abandon the SNP out of our
own I mean Nicola Sturgeon ski ask you
know manifesto today is
additional 148 billion pounds of
borrowing and don't tell me that's not
important that is a massive statement of
intent by a party that thinks it could
hold you know ed miliband speak to the
fire in government to be clear though
you're saying that this is relevant
because labor can't win a majority but
you don't know that so you'll be bigger
well the figures have you become a
solace from what would I haven't but all
the safale gist sino and indeed every
other he points out that it's almost
impossible that Miliband now to win an
overall majority given them goes for the
conservator that's not the case we are
23 seats short of a majority so if we
hold the seats we have a wind 23 more
seats perfectly possible in our system
yeah and then we'd have a majority
respectfully you have had a poll showing
a seven percent lead since this spending
review of 2010 but we had a pole with a
six percent lead last week for instance
so anyway the only poll accounts is on
polling day but look that the maths of
the election is quite clearly is
important fact because we're 23 seats
short so I want people to feel empowered
that if they want to continue with the
plan if they want the two million more
jobs if they want the plans in our
manifesto the right to buy your house
more childcare then they can vote for
those things knowing we're in 23 seats
short of delivering those things and
stopping the nightmare of a SNP Miliband
concoction let's talk about the writer
by then you reheated that as a Newton's
went over there this is a massive policy
that would give you know millions of
people the right to do what I suspect
you've already done by a row now so do
you think when you look at the policy
from 2012 that you or
and even in the 1980s a feature of the
record of that policy is that you have
not replaced the social houses so it's
easy to say you will not with this and
they'll be less it takes time to replace
you'll get the receipt from the house
you sell and you then need to spend that
money in the same area building a new
house and that takes time with the
ambition of one-to-one replacement is
absolutely there and the difference in
advantage with this policy because we're
saying that local councils should sell
off the most expensive properties when
they become vacant some properties in
london council robbed is worth a million
pounds without money you could build you
know eight flats for people on
warehousing waiting this some of the
poorest people in our country you would
love to be housed in the way that
they're not today it just rather looks
that you have this long-term economic
plan but just before election a series
of short same giveaways on housing on
pensioner bombs but i don't i don't
accept that at all what is short term
about the right to buy the right to buy
your council house was always short term
policy was a long term fundamental
change in our country that gave millions
of people who didn't have an asset the
chance to buy and own a home of their
own I feel that deeply as it conserved
is that something I want to see more of
in our country pensioner bonds it's on a
short term policy it's saying two
elderly people you've retired you've
worked hard because of the financial
situation globally interest rates are
low so here's a way of putting your
savings to work to give you a better
standard of living more childcare for
working families that's about helping
people who want to work more hours or go
back to work have that choice these are
long-term policies that we can afford to
do because the long-term plans working